one of the reasons i step back from
social media was because i if something
can manifest so
physically that you're having a [ __ ]
seizure
then you probably need to take this more
seriously and that was you know like
that was that was tough
and that for me is my happiness
grace beverly ceo founder of two
multi-million dollar companies
one's a fashion empire that's focused on
sustainability and one's a fitness
empire comprising a mobile app
a supplements business and gym equipment
she did all of that
while studying and graduating from
oxford university while growing her
online channels to millions and millions
of followers
while writing a book and while dealing
with all of the things that every other
gen z person has to deal with at the age
of 23
23 and on the surface it's easy to
understand while
looking in someone might love to have
grace's life
but as you start to peel back the layers
as we do in this conversation you begin
to understand
her obsessive attention to detail the
weight of her workload
and the personal cost of her
accomplishments and you see
the impact that those things have had on
all parts of her life
and it makes you reconsider despite all
of this
she's persisted she stayed true to her
values she's doubled down on the things
she loves the most
and she's cut out some of the things
that no longer serve her she's learned
she's learned lessons that most of us
would take a lifetime to learn
and she's 23. it blows my mind
without further ado i'm stephen bartlett
and this is the driver ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this yourself
grace i started my business at 18 years
old as well
you um you faced a different set of
challenges not only have you started
your business at an incredibly young age
or
at least you got into business at an
incredibly young age you face a set of
challenges that are even alien to me in
the sense that you are a woman in
business
um you are taking on various industries
that don't want to be taken on and that
really are sort of
incumbent monopolies in the space of
fast fashion and fitness and those
things
i guess my first question is why did you
choose business
and what gave you the
what gave you the confidence to pursue a
career that's filled with so much
uncertainty at such a
young age i think i think people often
assume that the first part of it always
has to be a kind of
i'm going to start this i'm going to do
this and i think that mine
absolutely wasn't that at all and i
think that that's what often makes me
kind of question
you know the amount of things that have
had to fall into place for this to
happen and of course you know there's
hard work in that but there's also so
many other things that have had to go
right
um so for me you know as i kind of said
when
i was 18 and working doing an internship
at ibm that's kind of when i started and
i just started doing some i essentially
started monetizing something that should
be monetized so it's content i was
giving away
for free and then i was going to do lots
more of that and so i decided to
monetize it
via an ebook um and then you know the
next year i did more of that and then
that's you know then it started picking
up momentum i started doing different
products and i think that
that's i guess often not seen in the way
that business is
represented it's kind of seen as like a
eureka moment then you go and do it then
you put it into action then you fail
once or twice and then you get it
and that it was far more gradual than
that and i think that
probably over the past you know so it's
probably been so it's been five years
since that moment i'd say four years
since the business it's ready that it is
now
has um i guess was founded um
and in that time probably the first two
years were incredibly gradual
very much a kind of residual extra
income um rather than
kind of this big like these are my goals
this is gonna happen within this time
um so i guess in that it's been a
gradual process
i think the confidence has gathered
through that and a lot of the time i
haven't been confident enough to do that
but have i guess just done it anyway so
you know when i was when i did kind of
my second set of ebooks which was in my
first year at university
that was literally because my student
loan didn't come through like that was
that was the only reason so
as in i don't think it was necessarily a
confidence thing i think it was more
okay like what are we gonna do in that
situation
um and then putting that together and
then being able to you know leverage a
platform to be able to
monetize that so and then from then
onwards obviously it's been very
mindful it's been very kind of strategic
and that's how it's happened but i guess
i guess the answer is that the
confidence hasn't always been there and
it hasn't always been a kind of i'm
going to take on this industry
sure starting tala that that was um but
but the rest of it
a lot of it has been gradual a lot of it
has been this kind of
more just a cumulative
making one decision at a time um
which is i guess what i kind of try and
show as well so that people can know
that it doesn't always need to be this
one big decision
and this one big business that's going
to be the biggest business in the world
it can just be you know something you're
just doing in that moment
the world has changed recently over the
last 12 months because of the pandemic a
lot of people have lost their jobs and
so
freelance websites and entrepreneurship
has now become more in focus as
people are trying to find ways to give
themselves a little bit more stability
in their income
and when i speak to my friends that are
you know your age 23 years old right
24 next week a week after sorry um or
who are younger 18 19 or even
older um everybody seems to have a
business idea yeah and i'm sure you're
bombarded with dms
like this right everyone has a business
idea um there seems to be this
barrier between the idea and taking
the first step like making uh the
instagram page
and is the the barrier between that is
it confidence
in your view what is it i think
it's probably specific to the situation
the person the circumstance so
you know i was when i was at university
if
you know i think that there was
something that came together to make me
do that but i was also at university
in a place and in a time that i could
take i guess
a a risky decision in terms of how i
spend my time in terms of what i'm
putting together i wasn't
i guess i wasn't doing a part-time job
at the time that i could have put into
that
and so you know part of it is
circumstance in the way that people
a lot of people don't necessarily have
the
the backing to put behind it or it might
be the the time they can
put into it you know lots of people are
working three jobs just to make ends
meet and therefore
you know you might have an idea but
actually being able to sacrifice the
time spent doing that isn't an option
and i think but then i think a lot of
the time as well i think it can be
confidence out of that circumstance it
can be
um or outside of that circumstance it
can be you know
should i be doing this why should i be
doing this and i think that
a lot of the ideas that i've had you
know i'm sure you'll
have the same like there'll be ideas
that you have kind of the whole time and
it's choosing the right ones and it's
choosing
and it's being able to test it i think
i'm sure if i tested out my first
i guess what has turned into shreddy now
if i tested that out
um you know even more gradually or if it
hadn't worked or whatever
i don't know how tenacious i would have
been in terms of actually making that
happen
and as i say it's been like an
accumulation of that confidence and
actually testing things realizing their
work and then
replicating that so i think
i mean i think we can't necessarily
blanket apply it to everyone and be like
it's because of this it's because of
this but i think that you know probably
the biggest
the biggest factors will be circumstance
confidence um
and yeah i guess there are so many
things that can stop you but there are
also so many things that can enable you
to say okay
well this is this is this i'm gonna i'm
gonna make it happen or i'm gonna take
that leap or i'm gonna at least do the
background work we'll do a survey to see
if my product would be liked or
whatever it might be i think as well if
people looking at you or
myself that have achieved things in
business will see this very polished
product right
and they'll think well i'm so far from
that so i'm i'm so far from being
capable
of what that person has achieved but as
you've described that which i think is
so
powerful and important for you it was
taking one step up
a very very thousand stair staircase at
a time
and and as you say when we look at you
now on step 934 we think oh my god like
you know you must
you probably get this comment a lot
right she's like you must be so proud of
yourself yeah
which is like well it's been one step at
a time so yeah you know and i think you
can be proud of the steps along the way
but i also think that i look back at
some
not necessarily some products but you
know some branding some
content some all of that and i look at
it and i'm like it was crap
like that is awful like as in i would
just scroll right past that or i
wouldn't you know
and of course things have changed
people's like tastes have changed and
all of that that kind of goes into
branding and product and all of that but
there was something you know i've sold
everything from
you know like t-shirts to notebooks to
like whatever it would be
it's not what the everything that's
accumulated now
is the good things that have then been
replicated it's not
everything gets kind of replicated and
then you know you see all of the
end products there have been some things
that never ended up as an end product
because they were so [ __ ] in the first
place that they were never you know they
didn't deserve that extra time on them
so i think you're completely right there
is this kind of and i i think it's also
perpetuated by
you know unknowingly often by people
like ourselves so
you know like i i think i look at the
stuff i share and i look at it and my
god i'm so much more likely to share if
it's this or
you know if this product worked out well
and
and subconsciously because there was an
end of that journey we don't necessarily
say like oh this was the thing that
actually went really wrong
because you know it's embarrassing like
you don't want to share that you don't
or you don't kind of think too because
you don't think of the kind of like
pride in the journey that's got to that
point
um and so it i guess it all does
you know you will just see the the good
things or you might see the bad things
that are positioned in an
inspirational way but it's still curated
but it's still
what i guess is want to be seen and to
to my other point about being uh a woman
in business
that comes with a whole unique set of
challenges you know i've heard you talk
about being
underestimated not taken seriously
before speak to me about some of those
challenges that i wouldn't even
you know know about so i think first
i always also think it is important to
preface this with the fact that
yes i'm a woman in business i'm also
white able-bodied
i was privately educated i went dogs but
a kind of huge
list of things that need to be
i guess contextualized which i've always
thought is
important and i think that i think that
it's
you know i won't face half the
challenges that
a black woman would face in the same
position i think the challenges i do
face are you know they are
kind of often and they have to be they
have to be worked um
through i guess and and that's been you
know
a journey there have been you know
people who
have wanted to work for the businesses
who clearly
won't accept the fact that you know this
i'm not the face of it like i am
acting ceo and you know i do do x y and
z
and there have also been you know it's
been the same with partnerships it's
been the same with
you know i think people people have a
certain perception that's definitely
warped and increased and perpetuated by
online presence and the fact that i
don't just
share my work and um and i think that
you know it does come down to it does
come down to these preconceptions and i
know as well
since i've started realizing this i have
preconceptions as well you know we'll
say like
it's about a woman who's high up who you
hear about and you're like oh god
they're doing really well
like why don't i have that and i think
you know i often think like oh well you
know apparently they're really hard to
work with or like they're like whatever
and
we all have these own kind of like our
own like internalized
sexist whatever it might be
preconceptions in terms of these things
as well and
i think that it often comes for women
who are successful you look at them you
either think
you probably think one of two things you
either think or maybe one of three
things you think wow amazing
must be superwoman or you think wow
amazing
but like oh i've never seen a partner or
like children like
do you think they're happy in their
personal lives or you think
wow but they're kind of like either they
haven't actually done it they've just
been put at the front of it
or they're like a [ __ ] or really you
know
really [ __ ] or like a tyrant or
whatever it is and like that is
and i think that when i look at that i'm
like actually that's probably the way i
see some people you know that's probably
the way that is
in some ways for you know for
for me and my conceptions and i think
that it's it's just it's it's what it's
it's what it's become and it's actually
obviously got better in some ways
you know it's got hugely better since
probably like the 1950s and whatever
but there's still a long way to go in
that respect
when i knew that we were going to be
having this conversation i i looked into
the general sentiment around your brand
and you've got a huge
hugely engaged wonderful community of
people um you've got this you know this
true
like i'd call it a fan base or
supporters that understand you and they
get you probably because they followed
you for a long time
and they followed your vlogs and they
like know who you are right and then
as is the case with pretty much every
um successful person i've seen there's
also the antithesis of that there's the
opposite there's people who
as you said we will try and highlight
reasons why
you maybe don't deserve to be where you
are you don't deserve credit this is
something that pretty
most of the guests i face um i've sat
with have faced to some degree
it's it's not easy to take right because
um i know right i come from a slightly
different background but
i know that irrespective of background
you have to work hard really
really [ __ ] hard be honest with me
how does that feel
i think that i think it's an important
discussion to have first and foremost i
think that
and i think i'll be the first to say
that and i think a lot of you know i
spend a lot of
time in the book for example
contextualizing success because i think
it's
very important especially when you know
you're presented
three people on your instagram feed with
in the same square and one of them you
make from school one of them's you
like your mum and one of them's beyonce
and it's kind of like this
democratization of
the news feed that makes everything look
the same and you don't see
the teams you don't see the privilege
you don't see all of the above and i
think that it's a very important
conversation to have so
to be perfectly honest i'd be rather
people have that conversation
and maybe write off my success based on
that
i think that i think also aside from
that i do think that you know a lot of
the people who
the people who do follow me and have
followed me for a long time know my work
ethic
and they know that i work hard and they
know that you know often that's been an
unhealthy amount you know
i use work as a coping mechanism so it's
been through the worst times of my life
that's what i know i can do
and that's what i throw myself into and
i think that
i'd rather that conversation be had and
me be able to know
in myself why i've been successful and
how i've worked
and i think that i think that that's
you know i guess first and foremost
that's important and that's how i'm able
to
i guess push through and be able to do
what i do
is because i know why it is i also know
that there have been things that have
helped me
and then you know i guess that doesn't
matter i guess the
important thing is that we're able to
have the conversations and able to like
i'm able to know as well
in myself i know that's a very mature
position to take
i've got to be honest it's a very mature
position to take but i
i'm skeptical as to whether it's always
been as easy to take as that and you've
you know so talk to me about the process
yeah i mean i think that any justified
criticism
or you know might be justified it might
be unjustified criticism is hard to take
i don't i think you can have a mature
standpoint towards something
and equally you're still going to feel
like a punch in the stomach of course
and that's and that's fine and i think
that
one of the things that i wouldn't wish
you know when i think for my
children that i wouldn't necessarily
want them to be in is i wouldn't want
them to be
in a higher profile position when
they're younger um
and because i you know i talk about i
have this whole chapter in
the book which is essentially a i guess
probably like the most honest i've been
in a long time because
it's you know as i've said it's a
there's no instant feedback loop
there's i can write this and not hear
about back from it for you know like a
year
and it's me talking about how actually
essentially i feel like a lot of
i became known at a time where
my self-confidence was at its worst and
therefore i was able to
i guess rather than feeling that lack of
confidence with confidence and
self-worth
i filled it with validation and
therefore when i decided to take a step
back from social media because i decided
that wasn't
what i wanted to do kind of first and
foremost as my job
that kind of bandage was ripped off
because it didn't exist
and that's when i realized that you know
these things are the things that we need
to be able to deal with and we need to
be able to
i guess cobble together to be able to
you know no matter whether this person
thinks x y and z about yourself
how much does that matter if it does
matter and if you do think it's wrong
are you going to do something
about it and can you still get on with
your day essentially
and i think that there are people who
are amazing who i see on social media
who i wouldn't give a single
criticism to that i can think of that
i'm sure get the exact
same thing and there are people who have
been to hell and back and get the exact
same thing
and there are people who actually have
done you know have lucked out and
get the exact same thing and in the
grand scheme of things i don't think it
necessarily matters i think what matters
is that you know in yourself
and you also know that if there's
something you need to change
then you can change that like if you
want to if i guess sometimes when
something
like other things you know like hit a
nerve or whatever like do you need to
change that do you need to address
that do you need to do better um so i
think that
that's that's kind of how i tackle it
but of course no there's not like a
something in me where i you know get a
message that says you look ugly and i'm
like thank you
that's not an initial reaction but i
think that you have to be
you have to be rational when we're not
designed to be taking this much feedback
and criticism or
even if it's not criticism if someone
like i say the whole time oh i don't
like that
color i don't like like clothing or like
whatever it might be
to the designer that might like rip them
to shreds or whatever it's not mean
it's an opinion and we're not designed
to be able to take that in so
i think that there has to be a sort of
rationalization on a human
part or on your like if you are in that
position you have a duty to yourself to
learn how to deal with that or to remove
yourself from the situation
otherwise it's just untenable i guess
um you've got you know two businesses
two key businesses and
um when you run a business when you're
young irrespective of age
you undergo a couple of things real like
unexpected chaos at any given moment
then also a tremendous amount of
sacrifice
i actually want to start on the
sacrifice piece because i don't think
people as you said earlier get to fully
see the full picture
of sacrifice and cost um both personal
and professional whatever
so talk to me about some of the
sacrifice that even you didn't expect
before you got into business and before
your business grew
um i think that at the same time as i
kind of benefited hugely from
the you know having money at university
for example
i also went to university expecting one
thing
and then actually spent it essentially
getting up at x hour working on
university stuff because i never ever
ever wanted to give them an excuse to
think that i wasn't
concentrating fully on my university and
then
working all the way essentially
way into the night to get the other
stuff done and i also you know that
comes with
being high profile that comes with all
of these things so i guess one of those
things was very much like there was the
time
and the life experience and all of that
that because things took off
quickly at one stage even if it wasn't
like
it wasn't that the businesses took off
you know the businesses have done much
more over the past year and a half or
whatever when i haven't been at uni
but at that point you know the the high
profileness
all of that that came with i guess
different to what i was expecting um and
um or not what i was expecting i wasn't
expecting it at all and therefore there
was kind of i guess
you know something that i really did
want for myself i didn't get but i also
got
um you know a lot more in another way
for yourself well i just wanted the
university experience really and i think
that i was
so once this took off i'm a very
determined person and i
i get i get a vision and i'll work for
it
day and night and i think that i
actually
got to i think in that instance you
it's kind of like a fork in the road and
you decide okay well i'm taking this one
and i'm going to concentrate on this i'm
going to grow the businesses and all of
that and then
i think as well i saw the deadline for
that as my end of university because if
i had to
if it wasn't as big as i wanted it to be
by that time or if it wasn't
you know whatever it might be i was
gonna
choose i was gonna go into a normal
career um and i think that um so
i was so dedicated to making that happen
rather than you know i wanted to grow up
too quickly essentially i'm
23 like i you know i'm and i think that
a lot of that has been
i guess in terms of people's whether
when it's people who meet you their
kind of perception of you or whatever it
might be and so i think that was
something
where it was a choice i'd make again and
again but it was i guess a sacrifice
that i wasn't
expecting to make and i guess that comes
with everything that comes with you know
relationships with friends
with time in general with
you know time to yourself time to
whatever i think
having a business in a way and i'm sure
some people will disagree but i'm
having a business in a way is like
having a baby and you can't just
you can't just like up and do whatever
you can't
you can't say no when a crisis comes in
at 1am you can't like
that is what it is you get all the other
benefits
with those conditions and so i think
that you know that's
kind of a constant one like you can't
you can't say oh i'm gonna
quit this and go and do this for two
years because
especially when you've got x amount of
people working for you you've got all of
their salaries you've got all of their
pensions you've got you know like
it's it's a huge responsibility stops
with you right
yeah and and and that's you know it's
it's
it's an important one do you sometimes i
reflect on uh
the business journey and just how like
obsessive it is and all consuming it is
and i think it's a bit of a disease i'm
like
why did i choose this to like it's
almost like masochistic
yeah like obviously it's got the most
amazing benefits but it is also like i
remember what
i remember my friend i can't remember
i think i really we'd agreed to just
just lock down things we'd agreed to
watch a movie
on a sunday night and then the sink came
up and i was just like
you know what i'm gonna like i'm gonna
do this i'm just gonna work harder so
it's just gonna be easier for this week
and it was like
tiny sacrifice and my housemate turned
around to me and she was like
what is the point of were you working
this hard for this many years if you
can't watch a movie on a sunday night
and i was like
yeah like as in like
you're not wrong like i'm still gonna do
it but like you know you're not wrong
like it's what is the answer to that
question though so say
because i've muddled over this as well
if i'm working obsessively every day at
what point does
is enough yeah i think that it all comes
with what you want and i think that you
know i've
i've listened to you before and i've
listened to you kind of saying that you
know there came a point that you
realized that it wasn't about money so
like what was it about
and i think for me there's the kind of
aspect of
it's it's for the businesses and i have
these really clear dreams for the
businesses that result in dreams for me
as well
sure but i think that that is
i think i'll come to a you know if i
decide to sell a business or whatever
i'll come to that road there where i'm
like okay what is it for now
and i think that knowing myself anyway
i know pre-business post-business i'm
sure
i am like that so
whether it's this or whether it's
something else or you know and i hope i
can channel that into something else at
some point that
doesn't require every inch of your being
and
i know i'm like that so it's kind of
like yeah sure it might be for nothing
but it's i'm gonna
do it anyway like there doesn't need to
be reasoning behind the fact that this
is
how i am i have always been
i've always yeah i've always been like
this i've always been kind of like
i'm gonna make this happen like whether
that's kind of through like
coordinating all the babysitting jobs
that you got in one night and allocating
them out to your friends
and stuff or you know like taking
essentially like any
job ever that like that i could
then you know that's all that's what i'm
like so i kind of know that
where did that come from though i
i think probably a few things i know
that
everyone in my family is a very
hard worker and that is very
it's kind of almost like an like an
anxiety
to do well even though like my parents
were
not pushy at all i think people assume
you know especially if you go to
oxford or like whatever but the least
pushy people ever i think that actually
it all
i kind of was discussing this with my
sister the other day was like where does
it come from
it doesn't come from our parents like it
comes from them clearly because they had
it in themselves
but you know like they both my parents
had careers when i was growing up i
lived with
my mum just me my mum and we had a
tenant who lived in um my mom's house
and my mum was
working pretty much all the time
incredibly
like i respect her so much for it
because i also never grew up thinking
like oh it's weird for a
woman to have a career and have four
children and like whatever she just
you know she worked all the time and um
and she loved it she
loved it and she gave her like
everything to it and so i
i think i spent a lot of i spent a lot
of time
kind of in that situation knowing that
i also wanted to love what i do and i
think there
is this mislead like perception that you
know like if you love what you do you'll
never work a day in your life blah blah
blah
but i also think that there is this like
it's a flow state isn't it like you have
something that matches your
challenge and your skill level and you
get more fulfillment than you'll get
from anything
and i think i was so i used to say i
remember saying like
i i think it was like when i was like 15
16
and i would take like work experience
from anyone every single holiday
and every single school holiday and i
remember
my teachers saying that you should
probably choose one of the avenues and
then you can do like more within that or
something
and i remember just saying to them like
i'm so terrified that i'll be stuck in
something that i hate
and it was like a constant like and i
don't think it's necessarily good i
don't think it was necessarily healthy i
was constantly so terrified
that you know the same was for
university the same was for whatever
like
i didn't get into oxford the first time
i applied i i
i and i went again like i literally that
same day
i went online and i found out what i
could do for a year that would earn
myself some money to be able to not be
i guess studying that year and went to
um and applied for the ibm future scheme
which is the one they do for
gap year students that that literal same
day
and then applied again the next year and
like as in
i was i'm very like that it's
very set on kind of one thing and if
that thing then doesn't work
i either want to do it again like it's
really clear to me i either want to do
it again
or i'm like that wasn't right and then i
move on but i know that i'm
very straight out and very
like i will not stop until like yeah you
get it right
what's the uh actual the business and
the chaos in the segment
can is there one day in your business
career over the last couple of years
which was your worst day
um i mean or your toughest challenge
i think my toughest challenge in general
was
there was this stupid stupid time that
i'm constantly praised for
that was the worst decision i've ever
made in my life which was that i was
coming up to my university finals
i was launching a business to i think it
was a month before
my university finals yeah i was
launching a business beginning of
may the 7th may if i'm right um
and i started i finished my finals on
the 6th of june
now that meant that 40 000 words were
due and
five three-hour exams within the space
of two weeks
and i also wanted to launch my business
and i also wanted to
do well at university i'd been working
with that for three years
um but i'd persuaded people as well i'd
be persuaded people to spend money on
this launch i'd persuaded people to you
know so i was going to do it right
people were like you're amazing like
this is so great like how can you do
this
and i'm like you are like it's not wise
it's not smart like it's not like this
isn't a competition for how many boxes
you can take within a small space of
time
that is like a fast track towards
burnout and
either something going incredibly wrong
or whatever and i think that that you
know like as i've said work was always
a coping mechanism for me so it's always
kind of like well if when if we
have to do it now or we like run out of
money before launch and we're doing it
now and i don't care like i can
work x y and z and i actually have like
a whole like
chapter in a book where i'm essentially
talking about like that was the time
that i felt most validated in being a
hard worker
and i felt like because i was i was in
the library at 3am and i was also
on the phone with the suppliers at you
know 7 a.m the next morning
and all of x y and z and people could
see it and i was living it i was like
hustling the hustle and that was when i
was like wow
like this is it like i am the hard
worker
like with capital h w and like this is
me
and i think that that is
like that kind of like sums it all up in
the way that that was
a huge challenge also an incredibly
unwise challenge at the time
and yet why did that feel like the time
i was doing it right
so that's actually that's a lot of what
spurred on essentially why i was writing
the book because it was kind of like how
can that be
the epitome of hard work when that is
also the epitome
of not being productive like that's
like completely unproductive um and
not useful for anyone you're not gonna
be nice with the people you deal with at
the time
you have a higher chance of actually
like messing things up and all of that
and yet why was that the one time that i
felt like
truly validated for what i was doing and
you were broadcasting that
and i was broadcasting that and there'll
be people i'm sure who see me now who
are like
she you know did this and that and like
yeah sure i work really hard i
really do but there are some things that
it's kind of like i addressed that and
like as i said to you while i was
writing the book there were so many
things that i noticed i was like i'm the
problem here as well
i perpetuate this how can i criticize a
culture
of the hustle culture that i
benefit from at the same time how can i
do that
and i think that i think that that's
what made me
you know that's why i say that this book
was such like a soul-searching process
for me because i was like
you know what is that why is that like
is that because i need the validation
is that because we all need the
validation now because hard work has
become so
unobtainable because it has to be doing
this job that job
like everything in between also being
amazing at self-care also doing like x y
and z
and i think that that's when i was kind
of like okay this is a challenge
but it's not only a challenge it was a
silly thing to do so it's not even like
a
you know there are things you have to do
there are crises you have to deal with
and all of that that will
be a challenge and will also be
incredibly rewarding and all of that and
most of them are but i think there are
other things that you look at and you're
like
yep this was a challenge and it also
didn't have to happen let's not do that
again
as you guys know i'm a massive fan of
hill i've been consuming the products
for about four years now and you know
that i attribute
much of my health and fitness goals that
i've achieved over the last 12 months to
heal
more recently i've started having the
hot and savory
bags of fuel and as someone that really
loves to have the ready to drink cure
it's actually been really nice to find a
product that is a meal but still gives
me all of the protein
and the nutrients and the minerals and
the fibers that i need for my diet so
i'm now on the hot and savory journey
join me if you want to
my favorite flavor is the thai green
curry flavor
i like to add loads and loads and loads
loads of cake and pepper to it because i
really i'm from africa and i really like
spice
so give it a shot you mentioned burnout
yeah um
and i remember reading a quote in a in a
piece that you know an interview that
you did where you talked about
mental health generally and how you know
you'd reflected that maybe you weren't
representing mental health in the right
way i think you said um
you were giving advice but it didn't
apply to yourself in terms of like
talking and being open about it
i want to know long way back i've just
been digging through every two and a
half years
yeah i just wanted to get a flavor for
everything oh yeah no i appreciate
home it everything but talk to me about
your mental health and the journey
you've been on with your mental health
since you were you know 18.
um well as i've said i think probably
a one of the reasons that i think i
you know in that in that pose to give
context i guess i said that
i am one of the biggest advocates for
people talking about their mental health
we have mental
health days like within our the company
like
you know you can take days off and you
can literally just take a duba day and
it could be
you know because of your mental health
whatever it might be and i'm the biggest
advocate for that and talking about it
and everything
and then as soon as it came to me no
like that was
not it's not the same case like i'm not
going to talk about it i'm not going to
deal with it and it actually got to a
point that i was having
seizures essentially um from
something really horrible that i went to
that was through that was essentially
ended up giving me ptsd
that presented in seizures and obviously
i was having symptoms up to the point of
the seizures but i only took it
seriously when it was a physical symptom
like when it came to the point that i
was like okay
like i'm being hospitalized now like
this is not ideal
at all and that was the thing that made
me slow down and that was the thing that
maybe or not even slowed down i didn't
even think i necessarily hugely so down
after that but it was kind of like
okay this is real and this is just as
like if something can manifest so
physically that you're having a [ __ ]
seizure
then you probably need to take this more
seriously and that was you know like
that was that was tough that was
right before my third year at university
that that started and
um everything up until then like i've
been a i think i have this like really
toxic
mental health attitude within myself
that doesn't prioritize it that isn't
kind of
that kind of sees it as weakness even
though that's the last thing that i'd
see you know in any of my friends who
suffer from depression or anxiety or
like whatever it might be
and it's completely different it's like
we don't get the same treatment like
i'll give you no i'll understand that
and i'll see that and i won't do that
and i'm sure there are lots of people
who are the exact same
you're not being compassionate to
yourself exactly and i think that that's
another reason why i really needed to
like look inside myself and be able to
evaluate that and be able to look at
like why
like why is that the case like why do
you feel so
undeserving of the justification for
like
you know having bad mental health at one
time and i've been lucky that you know
apart from
this which was a result of specific
trauma
i've generally been you know i've had
generally good
mental health and i've you know been
able to
deal with like i guess you know like i
think a lot of the way that mental
health is presented is really
damaging in that you know people do i've
had friends who have kind of said like
oh yeah but
you know i don't want to take
meds from my depression or whatever and
everyone has different views on it but
it's kind of being like
well any other chemical imbalance in
your brain you would because you'd say
like hey i need this to offset this or i
need insulin to offset this or whatever
and yet it's like a it's a thing it's
like a
you know what's what's she called like
mrs trunchbull you know
from matilda that you like have in your
brain that's like you do not like get
this or like you do not like deserve to
have that compassion or whatever it
might be
so i think like i've had a and i think
i'm what's so strange is that i don't
know about you but i'm able to talk
about mental health really openly
and i literally had so i thought it was
really important for me to
um i think as a business owner i think
it's probably important for
all i mean i think it's important for
everyone but for business owners i think
it's important for everyone to get
therapy because you're not meant to go
through that much chaos
all the time like you're not meant to
have three messages a day that could
kill your business
and yet you do and you're like and then
you're like the next like 15 minutes
later you're like
so what's that like your fight you get
you get like programmed to
get up again like second nature and then
you never deal with things so i kind of
i kind of decided i was like i'm gonna
get like i'm just gonna have it once a
week and it's just gonna be literally
like an offload
and i sat in it for kind of like two
months and i was like
i'm like i haven't cried yet and i'm a
crier so i'm clearly talking
about my mental health as if i'm doing
an interview and if i'm like
you know just able to talk about it like
yeah like i think it's important and
like this is
and it's like this is everything that's
okay to talk about this is everything
that's not and i won't address that
and i think that that's something for me
to i guess to deal with
and i think that the important thing is
as an owner of a business that
has people within it and then you know
and as someone with a platform and all
of that
all of those things make it really
important for me to
treat mental health properly both for
myself and for other people
but i don't think i do but you are
setting a really remark you know
what you said there about being a
business owner and it's important for
you to get therapy one of the other
points that i think
of good that you'll be doing by doing
that is you're setting a precedence for
all of your employees
that even me as the boss you know and
that creates a safe space for other
people
in my business it was the same so we met
we made mental health therapy opt out
yeah i saw that yeah so like and it
meant that the men who were hiding in
the back that didn't wanted to be tough
guys whatever you know i was going and i
told the doctors the business
my fat co-founder to go as well and that
week my co-founder dom said he got um
something like 11 messages from men in
the business that had been suffering
from mental health but just had never
spoken about it
and he became like the de facto male
therapist in our company for that reason
what i wanted to go back to on is the
point you know you talked about
this build up that you had which
culminated in you being hospitalized
with your mental health
um i had i had a guest on the podcast a
couple a couple of weeks ago
and she was uh she's a kayaker and she
something
something changed in her life and it
meant and she wasn't listening to her
body
and ultimately she ended up getting
chronic fatigue syndrome where she went
from being a kayaker that could kayak
for two hours
to not being able to lift up her hands
and she said there were these warning
signs in my life that i just ignored
until my body went listen if you're not
gonna
listen to me then we're shutting down
and it sounded very similar to what you
were saying so my question is what are
those what were those warning signs that
you were in some respects
by the sounds of it ignoring yeah i
won't talk about specifically
from from that perspective i do think
it's important to talk about
in terms of burnout as a whole
so when we i think the same thing
applies to kind of like
the way that this kind of productivity
like
rat race comes across now is that
you essentially need to be working as
fast as you possibly can it's not
productivity at all
it's working i guess if you look at
productivity like the definition
is that you get the most amount done in
the least amount of time
but that has fine like that taken as one
and then that's multiplied so you're
getting the
most amount done in the least amount of
time so that you can do the
most amount in the least amount of time
again rather than being able to just
you know do that and move on and find
that's good like we should be you know
we should be efficient we should be
effective
all of these things are important but i
think that
you know it's also the equivalent of
expecting
someone like that or a marathon runner
ultra marathon runner to sprint for the
whole marathon like
it's ineffective they're not gonna win
they're also probably gonna get injured
you know there's nothing beneficial
about it and we see
it from a physical perspective and we
completely ignore it from
a mental perspective or from a work
perspective
and i think that that's why it's so
important to talk about especially you
and me
people who are essentially will be seen
in some way
as like what hard work looks like that
results in success
or whatever it might be the
acknowledgement
that working hard does not mean working
all the time
and like having it all does not mean
like doing it all
and all of these various different
things that actually are important to
look at
from ourselves as well because like as i
said like i realized that actually
probably i was perpetuating a lot more
than i meant to and that was why i then
ended up
needing to perpetuate things because you
know i constantly wanted to show people
that i was actually working hard
which actually all it gave off was this
is how what hard work looks like and
therefore
there's you know it's probably stopping
a whole generation of people who
actually want to do something but
see something you know i'm not that type
of person i actually don't get up in the
morning and want to read like some
disgustingly
boring like non-fiction book and like
but actually
being able to acknowledge that and find
some middle ground
and find some realization that it
doesn't all
like it's not going to be the same for
you as it is for someone else and the
same goes for hard work
um and i think for for me you know
i now and i think largely because of
having written this book
i now see when i'm lagging i now see
when i need a rest i now see
you know i'm able to construct a working
week that essentially you know is able
i'm able to
be ceo at both companies and i'm able to
do all my work and i'm able to do
my own work too that isn't just
responsive to other people's work
and then i think you know and i'm able
to
culminate that in a way that is i guess
a livable way of me working
and there have been times where it's not
that there's been times where it's you
know
like hell to leather and doing
everything possible but that's a needs
must amount of time that is not
representative of what hard work looks
like
and then being able to recognize that
within myself and say like that's okay
like you're not weak because you have to
sleep like you're not weak because you
have to
you know like sit back sometimes or your
creativity just isn't coming out
you're just like a human or not even
like even machines can't do that like if
you had a machine like working like it
would go into override
or if it was set on the wrong thing or
if it was you know like doing too many
things at once
it would go into override so like we
don't it's not even that we don't
realize we're humans we don't
realize like limits at all we just have
no boundaries yeah and i think that's
that's what's important there's been a
there's been a big shift
i think over the last i'd say two years
there's been a huge conversation around
burnout right
and it's gotten to the point i did a
post about the day but it's gotten to a
point where
it i actually feel bad talking about
working hard and i played around with
that idea because
um on one hand you can be deceitful in
the sense that you say like i
i work 24 hours a day and i never sleep
and on the other hand you can be really
deceitful and saying listen
uh hard work doesn't matter self-care
and like yeah yeah yeah
sit back and put on a face mask yeah
like i don't want to lie to you i still
work really hard but obviously there's
nuance and balance and sometimes i don't
have good days
yeah yeah but i don't know anyone that's
really successful that doesn't work hard
i don't know any athlete
100 percent i think what i even realized
that was after i kind of went through
all of this like self-discovery and
writing the think pieces and all of that
and then i sat down to write the
productivity method and i was like i
feel like
gordon ramsay telling someone he's like
an idiot sandwich like i literally feel
like i'm being
that harsh just because i'm telling you
that actually if you want to get that
done you've got to get it done
and like i think that's why the whole
reason i repositioned it rather than
you know it's not just because as soon
as you're that then you're
equally as harmful in the perpetuation
of like self-care culture
that now has these knee-jerk reactions
that's either like
it's like a cult and it's like this
wellness thing or it's like
a waste of time there's like a middle
ground like that is important for
everyone but it doesn't just need to be
kind of like you know like face masks
and everything it can be
it it has to be like part of all of it
so yeah
you might work till 3am from
6am every night for a month
i would argue that that's not that
possible beyond that point
like it might be and you might be an
incredibly hard worker and you know like
and
i perceive myself to be but you
still at the end of it all you still
need rest and yes you're completely
right there's no
glory and no kind of benefit in also
perpetuating the completely the other
side you know
sometimes self-care is the most
productive thing you can do but also
sometimes productivity is an act of
self-care like
you need to it's self-care to look at
that project that you've been putting
off for
three weeks for the 50th time and
actually get it done that's self-care
like that isn't it doesn't have to be
you know this that or the other it
doesn't need to be compartmentalized
into like
you know some forms of work or self-care
some forms of self-care are
like what you know like it goes both
ways and i think that
that's what's important i think it's
rather than choosing one or the other
it's just real
it's like being realistic and being you
know you don't always need to be like
disarmingly like i've had a bad day
today because i also feel in the same
way like i can't be asked to do that the
whole time like
i don't like when i've had a bad day i
don't instantly think like ah i will get
the reward from being vulnerable by
sharing this on social media like that's
not my instant reaction
but at the same time there is an
importance and i do think that
people like us also have a duty to be
able to share
both sides even if it's that being like
you know like i was up till
11 last night writing a crisis plan for
something like you know like you
you constantly have these things and
it's like
and then like so there's just so many
different
types of i guess there are so many
different angles to it
and as long as there's kind of a more
realistic thing as long as you don't
feel weak to say
that you sleep or whatever and you also
don't feel
like you're being like really mean to
say like you have to work hard to do
well
both of those things are wrong so like
there must be a middle ground
and that the the left side you speak you
speak so i'm just calling it the left
just because it was the left
i raised my left hand when i described
it i'm not saying it's the left
but it is it's like
um i've always considered myself to be
more left than i am anything else but um
i felt somewhat alienated by this kind
of lack of personal responsibility blame
someone else um pessimism culture that's
emerging from that side and i in some
respects it's someone that's been a
social media for about
almost 10 years i understand the
algorithms will create echo chambers and
they'll reinforce
things and you'll and they're actually
polarizing us to be the right and more
on the right and the left
on the left and my point here is that um
i like to be a bit more nuanced so i
don't think binary solutions to complex
um
problems ever make sense left you know
rich poor black white
um left right whatever it is and i post
posted something about um personal
responsibility
and being grateful and things you can do
if you're feeling bad
and there was a lot of people that said
i was and i actually take this to
compliment they said i was toxic
positive and there's this whole new
this whole phrase not being too positive
being so positive that it makes people
feel bad
and i don't give a [ __ ] right like if we
also think we have toxic things within
ourselves and that's like it's toxic
but also like you can tell me i'm
toxically positive and i like
if so for example like i might be the
same in that i know that you know
i'm not i would consider myself probably
like a realist like i wouldn't consider
myself like a
constant optimist but i also know that
like
my coping mechanism for anything going
wrong is to make something else go right
so if that needs me to work hard if that
needs me to push
completely into work for 40 days and 40
nights but like i'll do it
but i think that you know i think
cor you know being able to label
something as something doesn't
necessarily
mean that it's bad i think sure if
someone thinks that toxic
positivity then fine a
i don't think that necessarily needs to
be kind of you know like
nothing is going to be nuanced enough on
social media for you to understand
unless it's like a 2000 word
think piece but i also think that like
these things exist like we all know
some of these like i know that i have
bad coping mechanisms in some way i know
that
i don't need anyone else to tell me or
if they do like it's fine but it doesn't
like there's no benefit here like you're
still gonna think that way and therefore
if you're sharing more of your thoughts
it's still gonna be like that
you might be toxically positive but it's
that's you know that's
you and that's what you're also gonna
say and like that would also be
you would also be lying to then say okay
well i'm gonna make this more realist
and so i'm gonna do x y and z and i'm
gonna put that out there
and then there are going to be more
people who say the other side so it's
like you can either spend your life like
swinging back and forth between like
what people perceive to be right and
you're never going to get everyone
because
obviously as you say it's completely
polarized but or you can
it kind of be like yeah you might not
like this i just my whole stance is like
i've read a lot of stuff about
psychology studied psychology for a
little while
i i've had my life experience and if you
follow me you're here to get that stuff
and you don't have to agree you don't
even have to like it and there's loads
of other and i think i just really
destroyer today
there's loads of places you can get like
fluffy you know face masks so the answer
to everything stuff it's just not here
because of my lived experience and i
understand i have a you know a bias
because i'm an individual that's had an
individual experience when i was
stalking you online grace i found it
really hard to find a boyfriend
i was i was looking a lot like i was
like i was
i found like i was like [ __ ] we'll
try google images google images
like these are just friends and then i
was like yeah i mean i don't think
anyone will find
a boyfriend probably until i'm maybe
married with kids but i mean as in
there's not good there won't be one
yeah yeah i'm not looking for it's not
there's a boyfriend there because i read
some stuff about you meeting this guy
when you're like 15 and then you oh no
no
there's not a boyfriend there oh there's
not a boyfriend there's not a boyfriend
but there's never going to be a boy from
yeah being young being
successful being a woman i know where
this is going yeah
so maybe i don't have to ask the
question i'm just saying like i asked
this question a lot of guests because
probably because i've struggled myself
right so being young you're a successful
woman in business
a lot of guys quite just going to be
honest would be quite intimidated
right you don't have to answer that but
they would i'm one of them i'll tell you
i'm not speaking for myself i'm speaking
from some insecure friends that i have
that would feel intimidated by their
their their partner who is a woman being
successful that's just
some men are insecure enough to find
that emasculating yeah
talk to me about the difficulties of
having
romantic relationships when you are
young
you are successful you are a woman um
i'd say it's not necessarily what i'm
concentrated on first and foremost and
just
just
from like you know i want to do
lots of things before i concentrate on
that um i also think that
one of the things that i i guess i found
because like what you're saying is
true um but i think what i find
comforting in that is also the fact that
like i don't
want to be with someone who finds that
masculinity so i think it's quite a good
um it's quite a good kind of whittle
down yeah because
yeah if you find it emasculated like
that you don't
any other thing that people might not
like about someone you don't want to be
with someone who doesn't
you know like my work is the biggest
part of
me and that's really sad it's not but
like it's a huge part of my life and
it will be and i would never want to be
with someone who thought that was any
sort of like great um and so
it doesn't necessarily i mean maybe it
will trouble me down the line
but currently it's kind of like yes i
completely agree
i think people do find it intimidating
and emasculating
i also think that that's kind of you
know as i say
that doesn't necessarily change anything
because it's actually not you know i
would have no interest in being with
someone who
can be emasculated by that so and at
this point in your life do you foresee
in the future at some point you wanting
to be with a partner
yes yeah yeah i mean i think i think
naturally i think a lot a lot of people
talk i'd say probably the large yeah
yeah and i think that it's important
especially with women not to presume
because i've made that mistake you know
yeah no i mean i've i you know i
couldn't
have like one friend who i think of her
i know she she knows that she doesn't
want to
like ever have like a life partner like
she doesn't it doesn't make sense to her
which i think is completely
i i think makes sense you know like but
i think that absolutely at some point
and um but i'm in no rush i mean i'm
very young
when that day comes yes um what are the
the difficulties you see in the current
way that you live your life
and forming a relationship with whoever
this person this lucky person might be
um i say the first problem is probably
going to be
closet space
i think no i think in general
why is grace difficult today and why
probably yes you should probably ask a
few people um
no i mean i think that i'm an incredibly
loving person
and i'm incredibly
dedicated to the people i love and
that currently is filled by amazing
friends
and family and people i'm lucky to have
in my life
and i think that that will you know
at some point as i say like that will
absolutely hopefully
be filled by you know that type of
position but i
i think that the difficulties would
probably just
you know be about around understanding
that work is as important as it is to me
and i think that you know like i've had
relationships in the past and that is
you know like that
does it does become a problem and i also
think that
you know then you can't necessarily
combat that by having someone who's the
same otherwise you're
never gonna see each other like i think
i probably you know would want someone
who has the same values in that way
but there has to be like a kind of
middle ground or there has to be then
you know some sort of way in which you
will see each other once every 15 years
or something
um but no i think i think the troubles
will be
around work and they won't be around
emasculation because as i say that
wouldn't be
you know then there's no space for that
um but i think you know in the same way
as i'm able to be
a great friend and family member and
you know all of that now it's
to me it's an extension of that to me it
won't be you know any different i know
in my qualities you know i probably
probably the part of the reason why
that's not what i want now is because i
also know that i
care a lot about that so you know if i
am in that situation i will give a lot
to that and currently i don't have a lot
to give to that
so you know i think it's a
prioritization for me and currently
that's
not a priority yeah how has running
business
and the way that people have treated you
in business especially being a young
entrepreneur i reflect on this in my own
life
changed you as a
friend as a person you know your
patience your snappiness
your tolerance i think i'm a lot more
i think there's a part of it that's
actually quite interesting that i've
been thinking more about recently where
if you're in business and you call the
shots how does that develop in
friendship
so i i've actually talked about that
recently i don't think i've
you know i've had to grow in confidence
to say especially to
for example men who have far more
experience than me and are technically
you know working for me like there's
been a point where it's kind of like
can i say like that this is not right or
like whatever
and i've developed that but i think you
know i think i've now developed that
well and i don't think i have a problem
with that now
and therefore i think that you know
there's going to be part of that where
you then like how does that switch off
automatically the second you step
through
your door and you're with your family or
your friends or your housemates or
whatever
and i think that that's probably
something that i'll
you know i'm very grateful that i think
someone once
asked me like how do you stay like
grounded and down to earth and i think
that
that i don't go for the types of friends
that
obviously my friends like bring me up
and they're my biggest fans but
there is no smoke being blown anywhere
they will be the first person
to also say you know and that's what i
value like i don't want to be
in a superior position in friendship in
family relations in whatever it is i
will never be with the friends and
family that i have and i think that
that's so important
and i think that that can absolutely
affect people
and i think that you know i've seen
people then surround themselves only
with people in their position or only
with whatever
and i think that you know one of the
most valuable things i have is that a
lot of my friends are
in entry-level jobs and i'm able to see
from their point of view what's the most
frustrating thing about their workplace
and not feeling valued or whatever
and i'm allowed i can make sure that i
try
like my best to make sure that never
happens for people within mine and i
think that so you can get those you know
you get so many benefits from having
different people around you
primarily like no one is kind of
there yeah as we say what about when the
bill comes
oh well first of all i'll be pleased to
hear that my friends like to go to a
very cheap place okay
which i also like i'm i i love a you
know
nice dinner and a nice like whatever but
you will not i mean
you you'll find me buying a bottle in
the club if it's one of my friend's
birthdays or like whatever you know like
i
love treating my friends i love taking
them on holiday like i love you know
but it's you can tell when that's
someone who's there for that i also have
the large majority of my friends have
been around
me for a long time and um i think
i i generally trust myself to be a good
judge of character i've got it wrong
before
um you know i've had things where i've
kind of like taken people on
trips left right and center and then you
can tell that like that was the aim
um but like in general actually you know
i have amazing people around me and like
i think we i'm
i like to consider myself a generous
person and i want to you know do things
like
like yeah sometimes i will just be like
i'll just get this or like whatever it
might be
and and i'm in a position to do that and
i think especially if
you know there'll be a friend who's been
asking for a workplace for
a raise for three years and it hasn't
even gone up with inflation and that's
kind of like oh
and it's not the it's not compensating
for that but it's being
like you need to be able to be grounded
enough and like
whatever to be able to still be a friend
to people who are in
you know either a very different
situation or like whatever it might be
and i think that i never
want to lose that so yeah i'll buy nice
things for people and i'll do that just
as i would for
any like anyone like my sisters or
whatever if they need something but it's
not
i think i'll tell instantly and maybe
not maybe i'm being walked all over by
everyone but i'm happy so
no i mean we find ourselves in the same
position largely right and i think the
interesting point is
you've been successful and the people
that you love you want to share that you
know you want to have good times and
good experiences with but being
realistic
mathematically they won't be able to
have those experiences
unless you create them right and so that
creates a bit of an issue for you
because you want to you know have good
times with your friends but you know
that
you know that you're you're gonna you're
gonna have to
create that situation whether it's a
holiday and it's not a problem for you
because you love these people and
they're good people
but it can sometimes create yeah of
course and there's a i think also like
the important thing from
because i know people who talk about
that problem but also
they love the flex so it's like okay if
you're complaining that you're always
the one paying for the bill and you're
also the same person saying for three
weekends in a row let's go to nobu or
even one weekend like
it's [ __ ] expensive like you know
like you're gonna like
that generates a certain type of thing
and i think that
you know that's not necessarily their
fault then but i also think that there's
a
you know if you want to be doing that
all the time and you're the only person
person in that position in your friend
group then you're you know there's a
certain thing that's demanded of you
but i think like at the same time that
you can be a good friend and be like
very generous and like like i
understand that i'm incredibly fortunate
to be in my position and i want to get
them nice christmas presents
like whatever it might be and take
people on holiday like if
you know i want to go or whatever it
might be but um
i think yeah largely yeah it's a
difficult it's not a difficult position
to be in like an incredibly fortunate
position to be in but there are there
are things that come with it and i think
that
you know thankfully i haven't been i
guess like
harmed by that too much and i you know
intend to
i don't want that to make me a bad
person and i don't know
it sounds like you're keeping the right
people around you that's probably the
most important thing right people that
will tell you when you're stepping out
of line
oh trust me yeah exactly tell me the
first person to be like this comes
across
awfully crazy
thank you so much
you guys will hear me mention a service
called fiverr quite a lot especially if
you follow me on linkedin and instagram
and this has been another week where
i've really relied on fiverr to help me
and to help our business extend our
capacity
this week we're having a newsletter
website launching called
mentalwealth.com which is being
developed on fiverr we're also
using a freelancer we found on fiverr to
cut the edits for this podcast
promo that will go on my social channels
and this is really the beauty of fiverr
even when i was a ceo of a company with
700 employees or even now when i don't
have a company and we have a much
smaller team
there are still moments where we need to
extend our capacity
usually because of you know we've got a
sprint or a project to do in a
cost-effective way
thank you to them for sponsoring my
podcast and if you want to check out
fiverr there's a link in the description
below that's fiverrwith2rs.com
ceo we've talked a little bit before we
go on on
we started recording about working
culture and how working culture has
changed and how the pandemic has shifted
things to being
you know um working from home what do
you what's your take on working culture
and how teams should operate and how
your teams operate and stuff
so i've been reading a lot about this
recently actually um general things you
know like rework
work rules like all of those types of
books talking about working culture and
i think that
the main point of interest for me that
i've kind of been exploring obviously
has been the idea of working culture but
how we internalize it and how our lack
of boundaries within this generation has
meant that we're
have no boundaries between work or not
work so it's kind of you can be working
anywhere and everywhere so when you're
not you've kind of internalized this
idea that when you're not working
everywhere and anywhere it's the
equivalent of like
being in an office and taking a nap like
just because you're living your life
and i think that that to me is the most
that stands out as the most problematic
kind of side of working culture within
our generation i also think that that is
that is coupled with you know like
companies like google for example who
are seen to have really
good working culture because they
support their employees they you know
unlimited holiday all of that
some of that is also a thinly veiled way
of making people work more because they
don't have to do their laundry they
don't have to cook their lunch they
don't have to
um you know they're not going to take
any of that holiday if they're given
unlimited but they do feel valued so
they work harder
you know and i think that it's really
complex and i think that it's not
necessarily like
i definitely couldn't deconstruct it as
a whole and i probably perpetuate it in
some ways but i think that
it's important that we look at it more
and more now these boundaries are
absolutely
gone especially you know i started
having some of these
thoughts and feelings when i started
working from home before we progressed
to having an office
um and i kind of was thinking like why
am i working more than i ever have and
producing
less than i ever have and also my mental
health is on the floor yeah yeah and i
think that then when
kind of there was the office exodus
going
at the kind of pandemic um and then
people kind of saying the same thing and
all of that and i was like oh good
and i'm like why am i feeling happy you
know the fact that everyone else is
struggling too
and it was you know it's a lack of
boundaries we have awful boundaries
surrounding work surrounding success
surrounding all of this
and it's part of a generation that i
guess bulldozes boundaries
in a kind of progressive sense but it
ends up meaning that we actually don't
know where we stand we don't know what
is good for us and i guess we
are constantly on the hustle train being
told to like do more think more achieve
more
like xyz without ever questioning
whether it serves us because that's what
we've
been put on like if you're a hard worker
you have to go in that like
kind of way and i talk a lot in the book
as well about like the
i guess the kind of contradiction
between the
progressing values of like a four-day
work week
and you know amazing you know places
like
um nordic countries that have amazing
work rules and all of that
and at the same time like at literally
the exact same time and often by the
same
you know people the same kind of um
examination of it
we also have this idea that you kind of
need to work all the time it's like how
are we
progressing in these two completely
different directions and we don't
necessarily know which one
is right and then if we're going down to
the full day work week is that because
it makes us more productive so
technically it's actually to make us
like
work more or produce more or whatever it
might be and so
i guess it's it's all just very complex
and i think that there's not enough
examination around it
in the mainstream i guess like you
should be able to if you're in the
financial position too
and you want to and everything like you
should technically be able to
take your work down to four days a week
or whatever and that
seems like the most ludicrous suggestion
ever
because you know you could always be
producing more you could always be doing
this you could always well then you
should side hustle and that three day
weekend you get and like
x y and z and so i think it is i think
it's damaging
and i think that yeah as i said and
there's something funny here well
you know because we're talking about
ideas that we would probably never live
ourselves
yeah like you're not gonna oh no three
days off for a [ __ ] weekend and
i'd love to yeah would you because
you're gonna go insane
but yeah um but i
but yeah no i think it's completely true
and i think that part of this has been
me being like okay
this is really unhealthy this is
actually problematic this is
xyz and yet and you are the embodiment
of all of this
trying to figure out but that's
important and i think social media
discourages that type of thought because
you have to be on the defensive
you have to say like yeah this is a bad
idea and this is a bad idea and yet i do
both of them
you you have to either acknowledge it's
a bad idea or not acknowledge it's a bad
idea and just do it
you can't have this like cognitive
dissonance of thinking one thing and
like doing another
because yeah like sure that's a bad
thing in some ways but also like
you have to accept the fact that you
don't always think what you're doing is
a good idea or you don't
you know you know something's good in
theory but don't do it or whatever and i
think social media completely bulldozes
that opportunity
because you have to like stand firm you
have to stand your ground you have to
and i found myself actually getting
quite one of the reasons i stepped back
from social media was because i
felt like i was justifying myself
constantly not to not outwardly
to myself because i was like i need to
you know but like if i agree with this
why do i do this and like all of that
and i think that i had to be like this
is causing so much like i'm going into
overdrive because i don't know how to
deal with
the fact that i have multiple thoughts
at once because social media makes you
linear
it makes you yeah it makes that like
lack of nuance
like your thing like it's the mo and so
i think that the
i think that's kind of okay where i
realized that like we just can't discuss
anything like you have to choose your
camp you have to choose your
like whatever you um when i first came
across you it was a couple years ago it
was actually on twitter and i think
well i don't know i followed you you
followed me let's just go with you
followed me because it makes me look
better
um and i went on your profile and i
remember going down and thinking here we
have an influencer who actually
like stands for something and that was
my only like real sort of
uh that was my first sort of take on you
another couple years passed by whatever
and i i wondered as i was you know going
through some of the tweets more recently
that
you know people just talking nonsense
whatever i i wondered
you know there's a cost to that there's
a real cost to standing for something
because then it's much easier just to
stand for nothing because then
i can't attack you for anything right
because you don't you know but when you
decide that you want to stand for
something whether it's sustainability
or whether it's certain values you then
are interrogated for perfection yeah
and one human step out of line we've got
you
yeah no absolutely i think the same's in
everyday life but it's magnified to a
point you know
in the same way i remember when i i went
vegan like three years ago now and
i um my friend said that my friend
the reason i went vegan was because my
friend was ill at the time and she
couldn't eat any dairy products and she
was upset about it and we were um we
were actually going traveling together
and so i said i would do it with her and
we were like let's just try it like
it'll be fun and i was like
[ __ ] i really do not want to give this
up um but we did it and then we actually
stuck to it and i was kind of like i
actually like this
it works really well for me um and um
i and she was saying how hard her
friends were taking it and how like
they were just like you know be like ha
you just ate that that actually
apparently has like this and it's like
it's the same
it's just magnified and i think that i
think that part of its projection
we don't like to acknowledge that we
think one thing and sometimes do another
in ourselves but we love to pick it up
on other people and i think part of it's
just
as we say it's the binary of social
media it's the lack of
kind of you know it's the fact that that
is
going to happen and i do you know you
find yourself doing
things the whole time where you're like
oh yeah we shouldn't have done that or
like whatever
and i think social media amplifies that
to the point that it's
so much more of a big deal than it needs
to be sometimes it doesn't need to be a
big thing like i'll stand by the fact
that you know
cancer culture fine like in a lot of
ways not great in some ways like there
are some areas
yeah really shouldn't be said or
whatever um
but i think that there's also like an
aspect of that that's kind of
you know we live our lives constantly
thinking one thing and doing another
like cognitive dissonance like we you
know
like you know you should be better for
the planet and yet you still buy fast
fashion or you still
like eat meat every day or like whatever
it might be
it's how we operate and i think that
that isn't allowed on social media
i don't think that's like a then like a
complaint i think it's more like a
that's how social media is and therefore
if you're using it in that way there
kind of needs to be
an acknowledgement of the fact that
that's just
like i know that and i know where i go
wrong and i know
you know like where i'd like to do
better and that's for me
to deal with so you know and so i think
that that's
something that we see across our lives
and it's just hugely magnified
when you made this decision to step back
from social media i know you hadn't
posted on youtube either for about
11 months i have all my dates was there
a part of you
that thought you would let this
negativity of social media win
i don't i think any time i've thought
that i've realized that it's completely
untrue because i've realized it later so
when i step back from youtube that was
about
that was a you know a bit after all the
things i've talked about that like i was
going through
and it wasn't right for me and
i just decided not to do it and i think
that also part of that was a business
decision
it's a like lost to income in the kind
of short term
but everything i've done for the past
three years has been towards longevity
it hasn't been about the short term
because i've been able you know at the
beginning i accumulated enough to be
able to make that change and to be able
to say okay well i want to
i want in two years time if i want to to
be able to disappear
so you know that's i think
rather than i don't think anything has
to be a defeat
like sure it could be some people
couldn't consider it that for themselves
like great that's fine then we both win
because i realized
and once again i talk about it like i
talk about kind of like the thought
process behind it
in my book and i realized that kind of
that was actually
not you know i had this choice to
be full time influence so i guess with
my businesses in the background
and i also had the choice to lean in and
really make these businesses something
and make them
you know like much bigger and have the
potential of
you know growing them huge maybe selling
one one day like whatever it might be
and i think that i decided as well but
actually what made me happy in the
actual work itself was the head down
get it done even like the crisis
management the working with the team
until three am the building of brands
all of that that like i was so young and
still
am that i hadn't even started my career
like sure i had
but i like everyone i guess anyone at
any time can
do three years of something then decide
to go to business school then decide to
stop and do writing or like whatever it
might be
that was my change that was me being
like actually what do i like in the
day-to-day
it's not you know whatever like there
was a lot of stuff that i was doing that
i did love
but i a i saw what was happening
down the line i saw that it was really
hard to maintain that after a certain
amount of time
and as i said i've always had this kind
of constant anxiety that i'm going to
end up doing and something i don't want
to do
which has made me be probably quite
proactive and actually being like
actually
no i'm gonna do x y and z to make this
not happen
and i think that you know sure like
there was part of
you know there will be parts of it where
it's like oh and also even better than
that it means i won't get the negativity
but i also
loved the sense of community i loved you
know at that time actually
i didn't get much negativity at all like
and i don't think you do necessarily
when it's kind of like just a sharing of
your life like
people loved especially the fact that i
was at uni for three years so i was
showing a really realistic like i'm
still just gonna be in my one room
home um like you know doing another
essay like it's not that exciting and
people loved that it was
i think because you know once the
channel grows it often gets unrelatable
which
you know people have different arguments
about that but like for three years mine
had to stay relatable because i was
still within that same room writing more
essays
and i think that i absolutely loved that
like i
loved that and i will cherish that as
part of my career that i really did love
i think i know that what i'm doing now
is what i'm meant to be doing i also
think i'm really good at it
and i think that i feel fulfilled like i
i genuinely feel fulfilled
um most if not every day what are you so
what are you what are you doing now in
terms of your
your focus and your um
i guess the question that i wanted to
ask to that point is
what are you as it relates to your
businesses like i think about the same
question for myself
what is the bit that you're really good
at and that you think you know what
that's the piece
that where i consider myself to be
irreplaceable so
i guess the more i you know as a ceo
or a founder who's moving into another
or whatever it might be like you
you step back to work on the business
rather than in the business right
so the more i step back i think the more
you then realize what you're really good
at because those are the things that you
keep having to jump back into
and you keep realizing that like yeah i
could get this person to do it and i
could delegate it entirely which you
know you try and do and then it keeps
coming back and it's not quite right
and for me that's marketing and branding
that's like the you know the thing and
that
is i also think that a lot of
successful businesses are you know
founder-led businesses
are the ones where i was talking to a
friend about it the other day actually
are the ones where the um founder is
product and brand
and they still have that involvement
whether it's just at vision and their
briefing at the beginning of a process
or whatever it might be
that is where the concentration is
because that is what the brand
is and we are in a generation where
brand is
everything and so the you know the house
of cbs the like what
you know the yeah they're all they're
all
their brand and and beyond brand their
brand bleeding through to product
and so you know it's good that that's my
concentration as well because you know
that's definitely paid off
but i also think that that's the things
again and again that when i was having
the discipline to step back
and to actually you know do what i
should be doing which is not being in
the execution all the time being in the
lead and being in the vision
those were the ones where i realized i
was like okay i have to be in this in
some way
sure even if that's you know as i say
writing a brief at the beginning of the
process
or mentoring that person through the
first few times or
being at the end of the approval process
whatever it might be
those are the things that i nothing
will go live without that going through
me not at every stage at all
but there are stages whether that's the
beginning the end both
whatever it might be it sounds
remarkably similar to
many of the founders especially young
founders that i've spoken to who have
that realization like ben who's been on
this podcast as well from jim shark
um even like huell julian who runs hum
where at some point
i'm speaking more about ben here you
have and to be fair myself as well
because at social change i wasn't doing
process finance yeah
legal all that nonsense i was doing
brand marketing
um we have that realization that um that
is your strong point it's also the bit
that you love and all the other things
the process the business stuff
those were systems that were created
long ago
and that there are tons of very you know
better people than you
to handle those things and it becomes a
case of where will my
investment of my time um return the most
for the business and i don't think
people have that conversation enough
because i think young founders sometimes
feel like they have to be able to do
everything right i think that is
the materialization of this hustle
culture i think a lot of that
led it's the kind of like idea of so i
talk about this thing called like
announcement culture which i thought was
a thing but then i actually looked it up
and isn't anywhere
so i kind of like defined it within the
book about the essentially the idea that
you know success is valued as more
within this generation once it's
announceable so it's not the
underlying stuff even if that was doing
more it is everything that is
announceable labelable all of the above
so
it also comes on a micro level within
our everyday like we like to tick thing
we like to see the things ticked off
like we like to you know we'd probably
rather see 10 things ticked off our
to-do list than have actually made some
real
thinking progress in a concept that like
whatever because that's
the way it's you know you feel more
productive you feel like you've done
more
and i think that that's also an area
where where
founders people on social media who
within businesses whatever
they need to be seen to be doing
everything to be validated and i don't
think that's a personal problem i think
i've had it 100
i think i still have it at certain
points but you know
it's a validation through being told
you're legitimate
because you do things and like i'm not
gonna lie
i don't know half of the [ __ ] that goes
on in our finance meetings
and i will sit there and i will look at
it and i look at you know and it's like
that's great and i need to be over it
and i need to have that understanding
and i'll ask the questions
but i also think that the second i let
that
fear of illegitimacy by not doing
everything
leave that was the second that i was
able to actually be a leader
because i was able to realize that
actually
what if if i'm better than everyone at
their specific things then we've got a
business that is as big as one person
like as it goes like you should hire
people that are better than you
at their specific disciplines so like
even if you're like if you're
micromanaging if you're
being like a bottleneck if you're like
whatever it might be
you are automatically causing
a problem or not even necessarily
causing a problem it might work that
you know like it might go to plan but
you are restricting
that growth that potential that
magnitude of the business
because you are and it's for your ego it
is not for anything other than your ego
even if that's an innocent thing even
you know as i say i still do it i'm sure
at points
even if that's you know like you want to
be said to be on this project that did
really well
and i think that as a founder you have
to get to a point where
that ego of course it's like a
validation thing and it's coping
mechanism and you'd like to think that
you always do the best for your business
but especially when we're looked at
online and when you know we need to be
seen that we're involved in this that
and the other
because otherwise people think you know
like especially someone who i'm sure
lots of people think i'm just the face
of the business whatever so like maybe i
need to prove that i do x y instead
but the second i stopped doing that was
the second i
as i say was actually able to do my job
remarkable when i was 18
19 20 starting the business because i
was young i'm gonna be honest i
definitely feared hiring
really experienced people because i
thought well how am i gonna manage them
and
are they gonna and they're gonna figure
out that i'm not that experienced and
it's gonna be difficult and so i look at
the first 10 highs i did and they're all
like kids
yeah i'm like why did i hire 10 kids and
then i get to a point where i'm like 21
22 and i start social chain
and i hire some really experienced
people then they go on to higher loads
of because
the person the people because they know
yeah they know what their teams need to
look like i always say in our companies
i'm like the most important people are
the people you have hiring all the other
people
right absolutely and that my life became
99.9 easier when we got better people in
and i
i fell back and stopped letting my ego
or my insecurities run the show
and the other thing which i wasn't
expecting is it actually makes you
look so much better when your business
works
like i i think the thing is that like
you've got to ask yourself
yeah would you like the business to have
the glory or would you like you to have
the glory
and like then realize that if the
business has the glory you still have
the glory
but you just have to wait a bit like you
just have to
not need to be validated every day by
the fact that you were involved on that
project that did well or the fact that
you signed that off
i don't need to sign something off if
the team is made of people who are
better than me
and like fine actually i'm sure there
are people who are far better than me
within branding but it's my brand
so like you know like still that's going
to be that's going to be like put in a
certain direction
but i think you're completely right i
mean i actually hired
you know in my final year of uni i
actually had three students
working for me or one student and two
fresh grads and they were great
like they were fantastic and to like and
i think they're
you know amazing one of them still
working within tala now
and i think that i think that that
actually was my only option at the time
like oh i couldn't afford to hire you
know like any more than that and it was
people who
i put them through like so many tasks
and i was like i need you to be the
right person because
i'm about to launch business and do my
finals at the same time so i'm going to
be outsourcing and i always say actually
a lot of the reason for my success was
also the fact that i was forced to
outsource so early
based on the fact that i was at
university and oxford had always been my
dream as i say i
applied twice like i was not going to
let it go i thought i deserved to be
there and i proved when i was there that
i did
and i think that that i was so committed
to getting to the end of that
getting what i deserved and you know and
being
proud of myself even though that wasn't
necessarily my dream anymore that was my
like childhood dream i was so convinced
that that was gonna happen that i had to
outsource immediately essentially like
and who was that first key senior hire
that came into your business and how did
it feel
when you you know you saw the salary and
you thought [ __ ] yeah so
so salary wise those those are more
recent those are much more recent those
are
within the part actually probably right
before i finished uni
there was someone who we hired and
i was like but i actually
managed to get someone else to hire them
so so
to work on essentially what would be my
account um
so the but even then i was kind of
looking at that and i was like you know
like that
regardless of who's hiring affects the p
l so like you know what and
but then more recently there have been
you know we've been hiring
ahead of product from sweaty betty you
know like all of these like the people
it's but also like those are the ones
where i have to like hype myself up
during the interview because i'm like
you graduated from my university 20
years ago yeah
it all ties in as well because as soon
as you realize that you don't need to be
that person
you also realize that they're not
wanting you to be that person they want
to come in and do their expertise
they don't want you to be like oh i just
want to check over this because
i'm the founder or i'm the ceo they
yeah they just want to do their job
and the better they do their job the
better you do their job the better you
do the job the better they do their job
it like it's all cyclical but it's like
ego and validation
and legitimacy that ties together to
make this kind of big old like cauldron
of like
this is probably ineffective but i have
to be
not even validated i don't think it's
vapid like i don't think it's like
you know i don't think it's necessarily
ego in a bad way i think it comes from
like
the fact that all of us have some
insecurity that needs to be
you know especially if you start a
business young and especially if you
feel like oh
like wow i'm in this position like you
have to be
you either you're like incredibly
confident somehow and like completely
full of yourself but i genuinely believe
that most of us have some insecurities
about
yeah and so like it's all tied in i
don't necessarily don't think it's bad
thing i don't think it makes you a bad
person as i said i have a lot
but i think you have to recognize it and
i think that's the first thing i'd say
to i actually had a
fellow founder messaged me like two days
ago and she was like i just wanted to
tell you what you told me about a year
ago
saying um like everything you know she
was at the stage where i was like you
need to be hiring people
and she's like but it's expensive and i
was like i know but they will pay for
themselves
because like if you you know like even
not even necessarily the right people
like even if it's admin even if it's
like whatever you
should be doing the things that only you
should you can do whether you're
self-employed whether you're like
whatever it might be
and you know like my my like i grew up
like my dad was self-employed like all
of these things and i think
you see you're like there are
so many different ways of working and i
was thinking because i've seen people do
things one way like i need to prove
myself and i need to do that
proving myself is more effective if i
have a team of amazing people
and that's been like one of my biggest
biggest lessons
i asked you then what your you know what
you were really good at within the
business you talked about branding and
marketing so i'm going to ask you the
opposite question
as the boss as um grace beverly the ceo
um what are you really bad at
big silence
kevin i think
i think there's probably like we're
going to bring in her pa now
i think there are probably a lot of
things i think i think there's
definitely i think one of my things is
the thing we've been talking about
getting involved where i don't need to
be involved i think that's probably
you know and i think i have an anxiety
around that that actually you know there
have been times where i haven't got
involved where i probably should have
because i was getting too confident with
my moving away
and then it just wasn't right and the
product didn't shift enough or whatever
it might have been
and so i think probably what that's one
of my main things and also
only recently have i realized how much
confidence i have to have in people
and i think it was actually based on
talking about how shitty some of
google's
rules are actually in work rules um the
book about
google working culture um he says that
like one of the most important things
at google is that they encourage and
empower everyone to be like their own
founder so like if they're on
a project like they should be founder of
that project and they should feel
empowered to
also like look at me and be like no like
this is not how it
and like and i think that that stood
with me so much because i was like you
know what
like the next day i emailed someone who
was you know hiring
someone within their team and they were
like should we get them on this or this
and i was like you decide
like you you know you decide we know the
end goal
any way we get there i'm happy with you
decide instantly
so that you know like because people
also want to be empowered with that and
also people often
you know do much better when they're
given their responsibility
and so i think that some of that what
we've just been talking about is
probably one of my biggest weaknesses
because i'm so terrified that
something will go wrong and obviously as
the you know
success as many fathers and like all of
the you know all of that like you
have to take responsibility when it goes
wrong it doesn't matter whether it
wasn't you whatever it might be
i mean something goes wrong right yeah
with your brand mm-hmm
grace beverly mm-hmm is the one that
they 100
hold responsible so in turn over but
also something goes right
for true but in turn over here says
something
responds to a dm yeah whatever you've
got to
almost justify that even if not even
justify it but it
apologized and it's happened it's
happened multiple times and
i think that how do you not then go to
the intern and say
because i i i think if it was enough for
me to do that i think it'd be much more
gracious for me to just probably get rid
of them as in essentially to say like
this is not the right place because it
also
you know there's a par there's an
element of that that's not understanding
the brand that's not understanding who
we are or ethos or whatever
and if it's that far out of line and
it's like okay well this is a mismatch
here then
but i think that so my two options then
e both of them involve like you know
being gracious in some way and one of
that is fixing it if i genuinely believe
that it was an honest mistake
and it came across wrong or like
whatever it might be then
fine and i will work with them to deal
with it and i don't believe
you know maybe someone will disagree but
i don't believe i have ever
ever ever gone to someone and be like
how dare you you've sacrificed this good
like like
you know you've done all of that because
also they do the work every single day
to make
the company great and yeah it's
frustrating like trust me like i don't
see that and think like
it's fine because last week they did a
nice post or like whatever
but like there is still an element of it
that's like frustrated and that's like
feels like you've taken 10 secs back and
is terrified that you're about to be
cancelled or like whatever it might be
but there's either a decision then to
decide it's a mismatch or to decide it's
still a match and it was an honest
mistake
neither of those involve like ripping
someone to shreds
so how do you do sometimes though when
you do get like emotion and business
it's your baby it's it's sometimes you
know
anger or i don't know frustrations they
do manifest themselves
in business in some ways like i'd be
lying if i said that i didn't have days
where i was frustrated and people knew
i try not to be as much as i can i try
and remain a little bit calm especially
when it's most chaotic yeah
especially in offices i think that's
particularly like we have the luxury now
i'm like
no you can't see me like as in you know
i think
i i often
like i think probably the near our
office the like cafes
they know me well because i will go in
there i will take myself i will exit
because i don't
i think in life and in business i don't
believe
in i don't think i necessarily
react in that way naturally um and i
think to my detriment sometimes because
you know sometimes you do need to just
say you know this is absolutely not
right or whatever
but i think it's the same thing as i
kind of talked about before like you
know i'd rather
work out the best way to deal with it
there have been times where i've picked
up the phone and i've been like what the
[ __ ] has gone wrong
like why would you do that like this
makes absolutely no sense like this is
you know you should know better like all
of that and
they are first of all they are very few
and far between i'm not saying that i
don't say that to my housemates i'm like
how [ __ ] damn
i don't understand why he would do that
like he knows that's not the case
but i would i don't i don't i mean you
might disagree
i don't think i i don't think i really
like i'm not looking at her
she also is paid to say no um
but i genuinely i genuinely i'm not a
she's the same way as a text
i think i'm the same in relationships
friendships like everything
i am a walk out of the rumor and come
back in half an hour and
at that point i'll leave the shout or
i'll you know but
i'm not instantly kind of in that moment
which is why i sometimes also find
social media
hard because i don't want to react in
the moment and social media warrants an
instant reaction
because that's the only way that you're
being true to yourself or like whatever
it might be
like i often will think something you
know when you're angry and you think
something you're so angry about it
and then half an hour later i won't be
or i'll think it's different or i'll
think someone didn't mean that or
whatever it might be
and so i try and even though social
media doesn't necessarily
allow for that amount of kind of like
discussion i do try and like
you know just yeah and that's kind of in
general
how i deal with things i go and spend
some time by myself and if anyone talks
to me
if you are to become the person you want
to become
what does that person look like in terms
of values the way they conduct
themselves react to things
um i think for me it's a lot of
repositioning i as i said like i think
that i grew up
on social media at a time where i was
particularly low and therefore like a
lot of that was made up with validation
therefore like i think one of my main
aims
and one of my main like work what i've
been working towards for the past you
know
year or so has been that kind of
self-validation and that self-worth
and i think that that through and
through you know unfaltering
self-worth is
i don't know whether it's even like a
reality like i think
people have faltering views of
themselves just like they do every other
person you can love someone absolutely
unconditionally
you can think in one moment like yeah
like you know why did they do that or
like i think that's a terrible trait
about them or whatever and i think
the important thing is being able to
bounce back from that into the original
position or being able to consider that
and still
have that worth or love or whatever and
i think so i think to become the person
who
i want to be i think it's you know i'm
quite
you know happy with where i am now and i
think there are
like i know what i need to improve in
terms of like and i think a lot of it
comes down to my own
confidence and my own um like assurance
in
myself in order not to project that
elsewhere
so yeah like in general i think that's
probably one of my main main things
being completely honest i don't think it
involves
like money or like growth in any other
way i think the first thing that i know
that i need to improve on is that
how how does one go about improving
their self-validation
i would love to know
but i think in general it's just like an
it's an understanding of yourself it's
an understanding that you're going to
[ __ ] up it's an understanding that
you're going to
think one thing and do another and i
think that
part of that as i say put that was part
of the reason you know i did move away
from social media because it was like i
can't have all these
people telling me one thing even if it's
a great thing because it doesn't allow
you to be like
completely in touch with yourself and
know those differences
yeah exactly like even if it's the
people blowing smoke up your ass like
you then can't get that from yourself
because you're constantly like clouded
by that if it's people hating it's the
same thing
so i think that like i'm don't i don't
necessarily know i think all it can be
is being in touch with yourself and
understanding that you are
going to do things wrong i think i'm
very harsh on myself in the way
that i don't like doing things wrong and
i work very hard not to do things wrong
and so when i do it you know it hits me
hard
and i think that part of that is
learning that does it hit you hard
yeah i think i think in general it
really does and i think that
i yeah yeah i think that that's kind of
one of the things that
you have to then develop that kind of
self-love and
all of that to be able to say um okay
great well like you know but i'm i'm as
i've said got this like
miss trunchbull living in my head who
just
wants one thing and one thing only and
it constantly changes and it's
constantly more and
i think that's an important thing to
address two things the first one is
instagram you kept instagram
yes why i like
instagram in general i think that you
know i think one of the
one of the sad things that i found about
kind of
pivoting was that i loved
what i got from things like youtube in
terms of like the community as i say
that like
i loved being able to share that and i
was at this really weird
point where i loved sharing my life but
i also didn't like sharing my life
because i like you know
and it was you know there were bad
things and good things about everything
but it was like the highs were really
high and the lows were really low
and so it's kind of like toxic in that
way and i think that instagram
instagram and twitter probably both can
be used in a way
where you i try and use it more as like
a
you know i post way more than like a
regular non
instagram non public eye whatever person
would post
but i don't use it as a platform for
anything other than just
social media like if that if that makes
any sense at all
it's kind of you know it's pretty much
my only platform
and i just you know i post as on when i
want i don't need to post
i don't need to come across a certain
way because i don't need to
do stories at all one day you know like
whereas yeah
and probably the most widely there was a
report out that said instagram is
probably the worst platform for mental
health well
you can see why visuals filtered visuals
unrealistic compounds i think i think i
think i also thought that no matter what
i didn't like or what i wanted to pivot
to
i also owed it to myself to be able to
celebrate my success in some ways and i
think that you know
that however many messages i get from
people saying
you know i know you've moved off other
platforms but please don't agree delete
instagram because you know
xyz like whatever it might be like
everyone has their people who really
don't necessarily really need them but
really really benefit from them
and i think that i also
saw a lack of representation for women
in the business space who also shout
about it and i think there's a reason
for it like i wouldn't encourage a woman
to shout about it not from a
moral perspective but because you will
be ripped to shreds and because people
will have preconceptions that are
different from
successful men and you know whether
that's showing material things or like
whatever it might be it's perceived as
differently
and therefore like but i did think in
that way that not only do i want to be
able to do that
i also think that you know i think i'd
like to do it also to make sure
you know to be able to be in that
landscape and i think that i kind of
owed it to myself also to be able to
celebrate that even if i was moving away
from that being my job i didn't post in
any way the same as i posted when that
was
my job um i post very differently but
you know it's i love it you've got any
sort of big regrets in your life
that you've uh that might help others
avoid making those same mistakes
um i think i mean i mean i think
my it's it's the kind of same timing
thing again it's once again it's just
anything to do with allowing other
people's perception
allowing focus on other people's
perception of you over your focus on
your perception of yourself um but i
don't think i'm not really like a
as i've said much to my detriment and to
my success
i've you know i don't necessarily
concentrate on
don't maybe it's that toxic positivity
thing you said or whatever i don't
necessarily concentrate on
those downfalls like i feel like
everything that's gone wrong
like we're not not getting into oxford
the first time or whatever that led to
me having a really great corporate job
and i was able to make some money and i
was
able to you know like work in econ for a
bit you know like all of those things
and i think that i'm very like
my pick yourself back up attitude
is bad in some ways but the way it's
good is also allowing
you to not have many regrets because you
always make something out of a bad thing
and therefore it's really hard to look
back and say that was [ __ ] because
fine even if it didn't lead to what you
thought it would like i had for example
i had my absolute dream job lined up for
april and it got cancelled because of
the pandemic and you know i
like was very lucky to be in an industry
that was largely unaffected in fact in
some ways did really well
and i was so devastated about that
um and like maybe it will happen maybe
it won't but like you know i think that
that was something that couldn't be a
regret couldn't be whatever
but i also know that at this point i've
moved so much away from
social media in that time that that
probably would have put me on a
like blasted me in a way that actually
maybe i wouldn't have been able to deal
with
and i think that you know kind of the
world works in like mysterious ways and
like maybe that wasn't right and maybe i
wouldn't say yes if i got that
opportunity again
and i think that that actually just
yeah i i guess maybe it is a toxic
positivity maybe it is like maybe i
should be you know i don't allow myself
to be sad about those things when i
maybe should be or i should address them
but i think part of that
means that when i i'm asked about my
regrets i have
kind of very little that's good i mean
regrets that come with their
their upsides right and the value in the
lessons that they teach you so it's hard
and i don't think it's bad to have
regrets i think acknowledging your
regrets is
really important to be able to move
forward um maybe i'd block them out
i bet you can't wait for people to to
get your book right yes it's a real
labor of love right yeah i mean i'm
terrified at the same time
um and i'm sure there will be some
people i think i think well i think you
it's the same as a business if you pull
that much love and your soul into
something if people hate it they
essentially hate you
like that's never nice it doesn't matter
whether you're a bad nurse or whatever
like it's not something you want
and i think that i think also as i say
there's a lot that i've put in there
that i probably wouldn't have talked
about online because
it's there's delayed feedback there's
you know i don't need to hear what
someone said
thinks about that in that moment and so
i you know
i'm excited i'm terrified um
but you know and it's also very
different like it's different from what
i've been doing
it's not entirely about business it's
not entirely about you know xyz
it's it's different like it's
essentially another pivot in one way
and i think that you know i'm excited
and equally like you know i think about
it
some like some for some reason last
night was one of the nights that i had
kind of like constantly waking up i was
like what if people don't like this bit
and like what are people you know
and i think that that's not something
you control control and like
i think the only way to guarantee not
having that would be to write a blank
book which i don't have much interest in
and is that those worries because i'm
because i'll be honest i don't have
those worries yeah
and i've spoken to other authors that
you know when i talked about them being
excited about the book coming out they
also didn't express those worries
so i'm wondering where those have come
maybe it's because i'm conditioned to
having a constant feedback loop
of you know whether on the businesses
whether on my socials whatever it might
be
um or maybe it's because i'm more
insecure about
those feedback things like maybe it is
but i think that
it's also i care a lot
so you know i care a lot about it i care
a lot about my
well-being i care a lot about you know i
and i feel like some of that you know is
acknowledged that it's not necessarily
even
the right thing like i want to be able
to write my truth and to write what i
genuinely believe in
and for someone to say i don't believe
in that and it's kind of cool
back to the battle we were just talking
about there so yeah you said you wanted
to be less sort of
connected to people's feedback well i
write in the book i write
you know at the same time like there's
i don't i don't obviously it's
completely irrational to
want to be liked by everyone and i don't
want to be liked by everyone but i think
in the same way everyone who is in the
public eye and sees something [ __ ] or
whatever it might be
you know as in it's just you know it's a
natural reaction like
you know yeah so i think but i'm very
very excited and i think that
the reaction so far to you know the
concept to the excerpts to everything
has been
amazing and so i think that i should
probably just be more excited about it
and
um yeah you're a you're a
very um inspired entrepreneur
i noticed this when i was going through
your sort of your history over the last
four years you've started several
businesses you've had
several ideas within those businesses
and you seem like a constant stream of
ideas right
i imagine that's also a problem yes my
early investors told me they said they
kept hitting me with this whip and
saying steve stop [ __ ] emailing us
with a new idea all the time
how have you made how have you been able
to distinguish between what's an idea
worth pursuing
and what's that because you could you
know when you get a little bit of
resource and you have
teams of people you could at any time be
the ceo that's walking in every day and
saying we're gonna do we're gonna do
this a new thing
that can be unhelpful i'm still guilty
of it yeah no and i'm sure i am
um i'm sure i am how do you decide what
to what
yeah i think i i think i use our
audience a lot i think that one of the
real
benefits of having a you know i'm gen z
so having a gen z led brand for
your gym yeah i'm the first year of gen
z
um and i think one of the benefits
is like everyone's constantly like how
do we market to gen z how do we do all
of this and i'm definitely not like
gen z like don't ask me to do a tick
tock dance but like i
um i think that in that way i feed off
our audience a lot like i know
i'm not the most experienced at branding
that doesn't mean i'm not the best at
branding for our brand
that means i'm not the most experienced
so how can i use that in experience how
can i leverage off
people you know how can i can i can just
ask people sometimes like i can just say
like would you be interested in this and
i like used to be like no because they
can only see it the final thing
and then sometimes people have said like
yes yeah and then i've been like
actually no
but i think it's instinct i think some
of it's instinct i think the more you
know your brand the more you really like
know your brand
and i think that lots of the time you
know it's
an equal problem when other people have
ideas and you're like
no but i want you to have more ideas
like and i think that you know it's just
a constant learning process and i'm sure
i've had
i have had ideas that have gone you know
that just haven't gone as well as they
should have and i think that that's
constant thing i think in
in fashion especially like you're going
to have
like a certain amount of things that
don't sell as well as they should like
whatever it might be
and that's just a constant reality so i
don't think it's necessarily about
always picking out the best ideas i
think it's about picking out
the right number of ideas usually fewer
and executing them well and as we look
forward to your future
i'm sure there's plenty more ideas to
come is there anything in the pipeline
that one might be able to know about
well actually because because i've
started
two businesses the one question kind of
press
everything always asks is like what's
next what's the next business
and there just really isn't gonna be one
for
but i think currently i am so maxed out
i think because i have two businesses
here but i also have my personal brand
sure
so you know the book is a business
you know and that's
a lot if you think of the amount of days
in the week yeah so you're thinking like
five days i'm really strict on weekends
so i hate to tell the hustle culture
crew but i take weekends and i'm
strict on them um and so five days a
week
split between technically three
businesses that's already a lot of time
blocking
to establish what you spend your time on
and where and bearing in mind that
about you know fifty percent of this or
not 50
40 of the stuff i do will also be
unexpected so
i think that as i've said the
kind of ethos i have about constantly
constantly pushing on and doing more
more more
is actually detrimental when it comes to
doing things well and so i think that
you know yeah i
i've had ideas and nearly started
multiple businesses and that this time
at one point i even wanted to do like a
mini essentially influencer vc of some
form and like
but actually i
want to prove to myself and i think i
have and i think i can
continue to do so i want to prove that i
can do
these well and i can have patience and
it's not about more more more
because i think some of that comes from
the fact that you know when things
settle it's really easy to push
for more when it's just at a settling
state and i constantly
you know why can't i push for more
within those businesses like each yeah
exactly and growth and wider more
breadth and everything
and i think that that's part of my plan
so it might not be new businesses but
huge projects sometimes within a
business sometimes take just as much as
a new business
and i think that yeah sure probably if
my businesses were taken away from me
tomorrow
i'd probably have an excellent you know
like another one the next day and that's
how i'm programmed and i'm
thankful for that because you know
that's definitely part of the reason why
i've
got to where i am but i also think that
it's been a big
lesson for me to learn that more is not
always more
yes that's the lesson that i also
learned and i then started becoming a
bit of a preacher to my friends who
would brag about having five businesses
and me saying one good one is much more
that's the thing i would almost
people as i've said people would say
about the end of uni when i was doing
you know like all of these things and
i think i recognized
probably too late but at some point i
recognized that it wasn't about that
and therefore i kind of was almost
embarrassed when people were like she's
got
72 businesses yeah because i'd be like
yeah you know
i'd rather have one that was doing
really well i'm currently concentrating
on two doing really well
and a third one which is my personal
brand which is you just yeah yeah
and then you know and that one will be
the key to longevity
for the rest of my career but so will
these two if they're done right
because you don't need longevity you
know if that happens and so
i think i'm lucky to be in a position
where i have many different
potential paths and the most productive
thing i can do in that moment is decide
on the path and
stick to it and i think it's fickle and
i think that i can be fickle
in like a hard work you know like
diligent way
because i just want to do more and
quicker and like all of that but
actually the toughest thing i can do is
just stand still and do it right
and where where does this end then for
your businesses in your view where do
you how because
when we're entrepreneurs we kind of
forecast you know five years time i'll
sell this or i'll do this or whatever
i'll step away
what's your thinking with your
businesses i think it depends i think
that like for example i often
i'll have a view i'll say like okay well
i'll maybe aim to sell this one in two
years and then this one i'll keep
on like and i'll you know do that
forever
um and i think that then it changes then
like
the other one starts to get really
exciting and really profitable and
you're like well maybe i'll keep this
one for longer so i think that
like i've got used to the fact that
that's not you know
there's probably not i've probably got
used to the fact that actually there'll
be a point where rather than
saying okay in two years i'm going to do
this it'll be like
[ __ ] i'm done like i'm done and
therefore and that's too late
but i know it will be like that because
i know i will push it to you know like
the end or whatever it might be
but i'm i'm open i'm very open to it i
think also
i'm very much at the beginning of this
like shreddy
four years old tyler not even two years
old yet
and i think that i'd be doing myself a
disservice to kind of be
it's exactly what i would do jump to the
next when can i sell it when can i get
all of this
but especially because when you have a
business you kind of programmed to
assume that
by the time you've done this
you're officially like you're no longer
an entrepreneur
you know you like sold a business for x
or whatever and it is a success point
it's a huge
you know it's a huge accolade and i
think that
for me i it's just about constantly
keeping in touch with myself and what i
want
what i want for the businesses as well
because i'm sure there'll be a point
where i'm like i can't do that
yeah like you know this needs x amount
of funding or this actually needs to be
acquired or whatever it will be
don't think it'll be soon but there
might be a point you know and there
probably will be a point that that
happens or
where you know we've grown hugely
recently i have a terrifying thought of
like what if it gets too corporate at
one stage
and then you know it's not a joy for me
anymore and at that point yeah
like i can like very much consider that
um
so i think it's very much like an open
consideration constantly for me and i
think that
the best thing i can do again is just
not yeah
exactly have you managed to achieve
balance in your life
well this is the sort of whole point of
the book i guess
but um
um i think i think i'm doing well at the
moment i think i wasn't doing well this
time a year ago
i think that i um i'm probably doing
well you know because
for example like as i've talked about
like i'm not in a relationship so maybe
like that would throw it all off or
whatever it might be
i think at the moment i'm doing it well
and probably too much of a focus on work
but
that's what balance looks like to me at
the moment it's not 50 50 it's not like
a tipping set of scales it's like
sure this is what's added up oh yeah i'm
definitely happy
i think i'm i think i'm particularly
happy at the moment because i feel like
i'm somehow simultaneously living my
early 20s life whilst also being
you know being in this amazing position
and that for me that was the main thing
i wanted because i just was you know
this more more more thing was like you
don't need to be acting like you're
40. like you you know and so i've really
tried to maintain that even though it's
strange for me to be in my position
and living with three of my friends in
my house or whatever it might be like
i feel like i'm having that and i feel
like that's
that was a real you know that was a big
thing for me and i'm
you know happy that it doesn't
necessarily have to be that i'm in
like some sick high rise apartment by
myself with like exposed or whatever
um and that for me is my happiness
thank you uh it's been wonderful
speaking to you i find you so inspiring
and you know people have said to me as
i've like gone through my journey that
i'm like a wise head on shoulders
whatever but you like really really are
oh thank you well you are no but you
like really are like you're 20 23 i
remember when i was 23 i was still
largely uh an idiot and you you you seem
to have
figured out no i know but it's like the
level of
i'd say self-awareness right and i can
see as you're speaking
in the way that you answer questions
you're also really you're really trying
to appreciate nuance
that's something it took me a long time
to do right so i thought the world was
the way i saw it if you don't work hard
then you are inferior
yeah right and then but i can see you're
being very considered in how you speak
and appreciating nuance and i think
that's the trait of someone that's
that's a bit had their life accelerated
in the public eye or through you know
pressure of running businesses but
just someone that has very wise um head
on their shoulders and you're inspiring
as hell
thank you and you're a lovely human
being so i want to thank you for coming
here today and giving me your
time and um when when can we buy your
book april
i know we can pre-order now 14th
15th thank you lexi
yeah i know mine is march so yeah but
you can pre-order now
20 something oh yeah well pre-order
pre-orders dom when is my book now
25th of march we'll cut it so it looks
like we've got it right first time
i'll pull up you can pre-order both now
maybe
so many people will pre-order the same
ones that you know when amazon assigns
like a specific bundle
people who yeah yeah exactly they're
like you can get these two together for
this
i think that's the aim from this do go
and check it out because i've
i know how much you put into it
personally and sometimes i sit down with
people
and i know they had some ghosts right i
create the whole thing but speaking to
you on and off camera i know how much
you've poured into it and when when
people do that
i think they create really remarkable
pieces of work and unique thoughts so
thanks again for coming on you're a
really really special person and i'm
honored to have you here thanks thank
you
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you